Bokkers: I get really happy
when I'm riding somewhere
where there's nothing.
To be out there just feeling it
as it is.
I've done
over 150,000 kilometers
over land or over sea.
I'm not a planner.
I know a specific region
that I want to go to.
And then from there,
I'm just gonna
see what I see.
I'm not going anywhere soon.
My battery broke,
but we're here now.
That's more like it.
[rousing rock music]
I don't know where
I'm gonna sleep.
I don't know what I'm gonna
eat or who I will meet.
For me, that's the adventure.
boy: Where are you from?
Bokkers: I am from
the Netherlands.
If you're open for that,
then the cool stuff happens.
And maybe someday
I will look back at it
and feel like,
yeah, I've had a good life.